JAMES BROOK: I'll start
with a quick recap
where we are today with
containers, and Kubernetes,
and Google Container Engine.
Oh, something went wrong.
Well, actually this isn't
a real outage luckily.
But for the software
developers in the room,
I have some good news for you.
It's not usually your code that
is the main cause of outages.
It's actually the way it's
configured, operated, deployed.
So, operating
software is difficult.
We have all of these
things to think about.
So, how do we
deploy our software?
How do we deal with
continuous integration?
How do we deal with scaling?
How do we deal with
monitoring without fear?
How do our services
discover each other
so that they can communicate?
Well, let's see if containers
have some of the answers.
Containers give us a consistent
portable packaging format.
So we have somewhere where we
can wrap up our application
code and our
dependencies together.
It's immutable.
It can be versioned.
We can stash it in a
container registry.
It's a really handy artifact
that makes it easy to deploy.
And most importantly,
it can run anywhere.
So Docker has become the
de facto container runtime,
and it will run on
pretty much any OS.
We get a lightweight
isolation, which
means we can disentangle
our application
processes from each other.
They won't stomp on each
other's application code
and dependencies.
Libraries can be
managed independently,
application by application.
And we can set restrictions
on how much CPU and memory
each of our applications
get, to stop them
from competing with each other.
And this is all
really lightweight.
So unlike a VMware,
you might have
a hypervisor and a guest
OS, these restrictions
are enforced by
the kernel, which
means they can start up
and stop really quickly.
And they're kind of
transient processes,
aside from any data
they might store.
And also we have a
standard control plane.
So no matter what we're running
and where we're running it,
we can stop it, we can
start it in the same way.
We have hooks into monitoring.
But does that get
all the way there?
I think we still have to think
about all of these things.
So, which virtual machine is
our container going to run on?
How are we going to replicate
it for fault tolerance?
How will we know
if it's healthy?
How will we handle
incoming network traffic,
load balancing, and
things like that?
How are we going to wire up
our applications so that they
can speak to each other?
And then there's
microservices, which
means if you are decomposing
your monolith or your larger
service into lots
of little services,
you have all the
more to think about,
and you have all of
these extra communication
paths that suddenly appear.
So you have amazing complexities
potentially to deal with there.
Well, that takes
us to Kubernetes.
And I think it has answers
to these questions for us.
So at its root, Kubernetes
allows us to schedule and run
containers on a fleet
of physical machines
or virtual machines.
And it allows us to cut the
cord with the physical world.
So, we don't have to
think anymore about where
our applications are running.
Instead we can
think about things
in terms of an application or
even a service-centric view
of the world.
Kubernetes was initially
developed inside Google.
I think we first announced
it about three years ago.
And it went 1.0
about two years ago.
And at that time when it went
1.0, over a quarter of the code
had come from outside
of Google, which
shows the larger community was
involved from the beginning.
And in subsequent releases,
more than half of the code
has come from the
wider community.
So I think you can
see that community
and the general
software development
community and operations,
is now the power that's
driving forward the state of
the art with this framework.
And the community is enormous.
I think there was a
"Tech Republic" article
while ago that showed that
the Kubernetes community is
something like five times
larger than the nearest
similar community.
So Google has now
seven apps, I think,
which operate with more
than 1 billion active users.
At Google, we believe
that running applications
in containers is the
right place to do it.
And we've been doing it
ourselves for 12 years.
And I think you can
think pretty much
any one of those
services that's serving
those users, maps whatever is
running inside a container.
Now all of this
story with Kubernetes
doesn't mean that your ops team
is going to be out of a job.
The Google ops team, the core
ops teams continue to grow.
But the number of
containers in our fleet
has grown over 10 times faster.
So to tell us a bit about
Kubernetes in the wild,
I'm really excited to invite
our friend from Excite
to the stage.
So please give Hygo
a round of applause.
And he's going to tell us.
[APPLAUSE]
HYGO REINALDO: Hello, guys.
Thank you, James.
Thank you all for coming.
It's great to be
here today to talk
a bit about Xite,
Kubernetes, and Google Cloud
Platform with UI.
For starting, what
we do at Xite?
Well, Xite, it's personalized
music and television channel.
You could see it as Spotify
or Netflix for music videos.
And our application, it runs
on top of a linear channel.
And based on what
our user decides,
like keep, skip,
or like music; we
keep doing indications for the
recommendations in real time.
And we have now more than 100K
music videos in our database
and this amount
only grows each day.
This is how the
application looks like.
On your TV, you can
have different kind
of channels like
just rock music,
or you can really
personalize it.
And depending on
the actions, this
is what it looks like on your
TV when a user likes a video.
This is what it looks like
when he or she skips it.
Of course, you can watch
straight away on your TV.
And based on the actions
that the user just took,
our algorithm improves the video
recommendation in real time.
As you can see, now we are
improving that channel.
So it's actually a very cool
thing to run and to maintain.
And if you want to
test that by yourself,
we invite you all to go to
Ziggo if you have channel 25.
This is nice.
Now let's go to the
cool part, coolest.
When I first started at at Xite,
I found this infrastructure--
running on premises and
encoding a video on Mac Minis.
As you can imagine, a lot of
things could go wrong there.
And it did.
So we had all kind of
outages, like crashing
servers, limited storage
capacity, power--
electricity power, sometimes
we had electric power
out in our building
and then we need
to send the entire
music department home,
because they could not work.
And of course one
of the main problems
also, the solution on premises
was not scalable at all.
If we need to
encode more videos,
then we need to
add more Mac Minis
and keep maintaining these.
So this was not good.
So the first thing that came
to my mind when I arrived
was, not how I would
keep any of these.
We are going to
rebuild everything.
And about this new platform
that we would start,
well I knew three things
for sure about it.
First of all, it had
to be cloud agnostic.
Because at Xite, it is
very important for us
to be sure that our
users, they have
been provided with the
best service possible
we can offer to them.
And we do believe that
to be able to choose
which cloud platform we are
going to run all solutions,
its an essential
part of this process.
So the platform, the
solution, the new one
had to be cloud agnostic.
And of course, open source
community had to be behind it.
Because I do know-- we do know
how important the open source
community is for any project.
And the great news James just
gave us that now more than 50%
of the code of Kubernetes,
they came from the community.
And another important factor
about this new platform
was that I want it to
be fast and efficient.
Fast at the point that we
could reply all API requests
in like small milliseconds,
and efficient at the point
that we can encode 4K videos,
cheap in an affordable way.
So after analyzing these
three conditions, these three
main conditions, it was
clear that Kubernetes
would be a great choice for us.
And we went for it.
After we decided
going for Kubernetes,
why to go for Google
Container Engine?
If you don't know,
Google Container Engine
is the Google solution
for hosting containers.
Well, so why going for it and
not going to any other cloud
provider?
As you know, Kubernetes can run
in multiple different places.
Well, the first
reason why we decided
going for Google
Container Engine
was the fact that it's already
itself a Kubernetes cluster.
Which means the Container
Engine itself is already
running inside Kubernetes.
And this a pretty
cool thing, and it
also proves that the
technology works.
After that, another
important point
on choosing Google
Container Engine platform
was the fact that their Google
key manager, is the Kubernetes
master for you.
And this saves a
long amount of time.
Instead of managing the
master, updating it,
I just left this job to Google.
And I keep focused on
making the cluster better.
And this is like a
huge, huge advantage.
And another thing that we went
for Google Container Engine
is the cost benefit.
They have all kind of discounts
if you keep your server
running for the full month,
all the weeks of-- all
the days of the month,
you get immediately
a sustained use discount
on your VM, which
can be around 30% of its price.
So it's actually a very
good cost efficient.
So we decided to go
for Kubernetes, then
Google Container Engine.
And this was a good choice.
So I will talk to
you now how we're
doing encoding videos on
Kubernetes and Google Container
Engine.
Actually our encoding
process, it's very efficient.
Every time we need to
encode a new video,
Kubernetes starts a
POD, encoding POD,
on a preemptable VM, 32 vcpus.
Disapprove And the
only job of this POD
is to encode that
specific video.
When it's done, Kubernetes
will automatically
destroy the POD and
also the preemptable VM.
If you don't know what a
preemptable VM is, well,
a good way to
explain, this is more
like an access of
computing resources
on that specific
Google data center.
So Google is not
using at that moment,
so Google offers you to
have a VM as a preemptable.
Which means that this VM is
going to run up to 24 hours.
However, it can be destroyed
by end-time by Google,
with just 30 seconds notice
if this access of computing
resources is needed somewhere
else in the data center.
However, they can cost up to
80% cheaper than a regular VM.
So its actually a good deal.
You can see a preemptable
VM as a beautiful butterfly.
Its going to arrive to your life
fast, make it better, bright,
and suddenly this is out.
So your application also
has to be able to handle it,
in case of a resilient
problem which
happens because the preemptable
machine was destroyed.
However, this works
pretty good for us.
And this is one proof that the
integration between Kubernetes
and Google Cloud
Platform works great.
We use Kubernetes node selector
to define on which node pool
that specific POD should start.
A node pool, it's a Google
Container Compute Engine
individually.
It allows you to deploy several
different group of machines
that contain the
same hardware on it.
And it's a very nice feature.
Because in our case,
we can have a node pool
with 32 vcpus preemptable VMs
just for encoding PODs there.
And then on the same
Kubernetes cluster,
we can have a different node
pool with a 4-CPU machine
only for running our API POD.
So this integration
is very powerful.
Because you can use the right
hardware for the right job.
And this, in the
end it saves money.
Another cool thing
we use on Kubernetes
is, of course, the Kubernetes
horizontal pod autoscaling.
This means that
Kubernetes has the ability
to increase and decrease
the number of pods
automatically when it's needed.
In our case, our
API in the morning
we have less people using it.
So Kubernetes, it
automatically keeps
the amount of pods running
at the minimal level.
However, in the
afternoon, the evening,
when we have more people
watching our channel--
more traffic
arriving, Kubernetes
can detect it, and automatically
increase the amount of pods.
So our platform is ready
for this new data arriving,
for this new traffic.
And we can still keep
replying in the prime.
As soon as Kubernetes
realizes these resources are
no longer needed, it
will automatically
decrease your platform down.
So this also saves
money for you.
Because you don't need to
run more resources than what
is really needed on that moment.
Another big problem we
had was about the storage.
And the Google Nearline
storage, it really
solves all the problems we had.
It's a great speed cost benefit.
You can retrieve data faster
in like around one second.
The cost is only around 10
euros per month for a terabyte.
And this is really midfield
between regular storage
and a disk attached straight
away to your machine.
Because it works
fast, we can even
play some previews of
4K video to our OC,
straight away from the storage.
When we started, I didn't
imagine this could be possible.
But it works pretty
good, actually.
So the main question, $1 million
question, was it all worth it?
Yes, it was.
If your company is thinking
about migrating to Kubernetes,
you should start it right now.
It has great
benefits, of course,
a bit of work to get it done.
And Google Cloud Platform
really helps you to deploy it.
So now, right now we have
our main applications running
already on Kubernetes,
no longer we need
this in-house infrastructure.
Thanks, god.
And we can encode
machines with preemptable
very fast and efficient for us.
It's cheap.
Actually it's 15 times faster
now, the encoding process,
than what it was in-house.
And the preemptables make
it really affordable.
And the Nearline storage
at Google, really fixed
all our problems related
to storage capacity,
and electricity outage.
We don't have anything of
that anymore, of course.
And the most important
aspect, reliability.
We can't trust, we can
rely more on our software
that it's going to work.
Because we have
no longer hardware
issues or electricity issues.
It works way better than before.
What's next for us at Xite?
Well, Xite is growing very fast.
We're going to be probably
in 25 different countries
in the next two or three years.
So of course I want to
federate everything.
I want all my clusters
that I'm going
to release on different zones
around the world to connect,
to integrate, to
put my customers
to talk to each
other, if needed.
And another thing that we are
missing a bit on Kubernetes,
and I have good news
that we're going
to have before in a bit
from James, it's Istio.
It's a servicing mesh system
that we're going to need.
Matt talked a bit about it.
And I'm looking forward
to implementing it.
It's important for us at Xite
to keep using top technologies.
And Istio I do believe is
the next new thing coming.
And this will be a
real game changer
for Kubernetes clusters.
Well, if you have any
questions, this was it for me.
I will be around.
It will be great to talk to
you about Xite, Kubernetes,
or anything on Google
Cloud Platform.
Thank you very much for coming.
And this was it.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, James.
JAMES BROOK: Thank you, Hygo.
So, I know many of you are
probably getting hungry.
And it's going to get a little
bit nerdy from this point
onwards.
So, try to keep your brains
running for a little bit
longer.
So let's talk about
using capacity
efficiently for a moment.
So many people in
the room might be
familiar with the feeling of
having a few processes, say,
running on a VM or a few VMs.
And it doesn't feel logical to
put some other processes there,
so you leave it like that.
But the VM is largely idling.
The machine is not
using all of the memory
and CPU available to it.
Well the Kubernetes Scheduler is
really good at playing Tetris.
I think that's a good
way to think about it.
It knows how to pack
those containers
into the available capacity
really efficiently.
But I've heard it said
that you could even
quadruple the effective
capacity of your data center
in this way.
But for some people
that's not enough.
So, let's talk about how you
could run a 5,000 node cluster.
So maybe there's someone
in the room who would like
to run a 5,000 node cluster.
I've definitely
got colleagues who
would be interested in
talking to you afterwards.
So if you run a
5,000 node cluster,
and you used our 64
core machines which
have launched quite
recently, I think
you would have 233,600,000
core hours per month.
And you'd be paying about
$7 million a month for that.
But once the sustained
use discount kicked in,
I think you'd get it
down to under $4 million.
But obviously not
everybody wants to do that.
The good news, though, is that
because we operate clusters
at scales like that, everyone
benefits in terms of latency.
So we have design
targets that are APIs.
The Kubernetes APIs should
respond in under one second
and that pods should start
up within five seconds.
So, if you--
Hygo mentioned federation.
If you wanted to have the
ultimate high-availability
solution, you could run
a cluster in each region
where you had customers
around the world
and get them to join a club,
which is called a federation,
and get some sort of
centralized control
over the components in it.
And at the same time, you
could have a single global load
balancer in front of it,
which would automatically
take care of routing
your clients'
requests to the nearest
healthy cluster in the world.
So as your clusters grow and
your operations teams grow,
you probably need
to think about how
you're going to control
access to all of these things.
All your eggs could be in
one basket now, otherwise.
So in the past here we have
a blue team and a green team.
If these people had access to
the cluster to change things,
then that was it.
They could do what they liked.
Then along came
namespaces, which
gave us some form of
separation, but not
really enforced with teeth.
So, you could separate
out your concerns here.
But you could just
do things like, say,
the blue team will get
a certain amount of CPU
and memory and the green
team will get the rest.
But now with role-based access
control that can be enforced.
So if you have a user,
a group, or a service
account and a resource that
you want to control access to--
and a resource doesn't just
have to be a namespace.
Here we have that as an example.
It could be a pod.
Or it could even be, say,
read access to the logs
that that pod writes.
Now you can have a role, which
will play a part in connecting
those things together.
So a role could be an
out-of-the-box role,
so cluster admin ride the
way down to a custom role
of somebody who could write
or read a particular resource
or even a combination
of resources.
And you can connect them
together with a role binding,
giving you that fine
grained access control.
Another thing is storage.
So earlier we talked
about disconnecting
from the physical
world and just thinking
about our application and
our service-centric view
of the world.
Unfortunately, storage
seems to take us back
to that physical world.
And people may be
familiar with the days
when they had to
request storage,
say, their server
or their cluster
was running low and
panicking about the database,
causing it to
overflow and crash.
You would actually have
to request storage.
Maybe someone would
have to rack it.
More recently, someone might--
separately still, an ops team,
perhaps-- might provision it
with your cloud provider.
And then they would attach it
to a node or a VM, which still
doesn't quite fit in with
this service-centric view
of the world we've
been talking about.
Because your pod
might one day be
running on one node or
VM, and then the next day
it might be on another.
So for a while we've had
persistent volume claims,
which give you a
means of associating
your storage after you've
provisioned it with a running
pod.
Wouldn't it be nice if
we could automate that?
Well now, we can do that
with dynamic provisioning.
So if a pod starts up and it
has a persistent volume claim
and it wants to have this
storage associated with it,
if it doesn't already
have access to the storage
that storage can just
be created on the fly.
And we also have something
called storage classes, which
is basically a blueprint for
a certain type of storage
you might have, say, different
cloud providers, or some SSDs.
And you can effectively
give it a label
and make an abstraction
there, and say, the SSD
is your gold storage
or your fast storage.
So then all your persistent
volume claim has to do is say,
I want this kind of storage,
and I want this amount of it.
And it will get sorted out.
So I think we're back in
the application-centric view
of the world.
So we talked about all these
high-availability features.
Now we have some new
scheduling challenges as well.
So you could run a cluster
across multiple availability
zones already.
And by default, the scheduler
will just put the containers
in the first free node that
it finds without much regard
to where things should be.
So you can have some
extra use cases.
For instance, you
have a legacy service
running on a VM
in zone C. And you
want to run some pods,
which particularly need
to talk to that legacy service.
I think you might like
them to be together,
because you want to
minimize and avoid
that little bit of
latency that comes
with talking in between zones,
and some small costs as well.
Or you might be like Hygo.
And you might have
a special node pool
with special hardware
for video encoding.
And you want your pods
to run in that node pool.
Well now we have extra control
over that with something
called node affinity.
So in this we have our legacy
service running in zone C.
And we want to schedule
a pod next to it.
And we can configure that
in something like this.
Now, I know this looks
like YAML on a slide,
and lunch is nearly here.
But its a bit like
poetry, I think.
If you keep saying
require during scheduling,
ignore during execution, there's
something wonderful about that.
And I think if you think
about what that means,
it means that here
we've got something
like a key and a value.
So we're saying that
our key is our failure
domain, in this case a zone.
And we want our pod to be
landing in zone C here.
And we actually require that.
So that is a strong requirement.
We could also say that we'd
prefer during scheduling,
ignore during execution.
And unlike node selector, we
get these extra operators,
including some
exclusive operators that
would let us repel workloads
from that particular key,
and some standard keys.
So we have failure domains,
zone and region, host name,
and you can have custom things,
also preemptables, SSDs;
that sort of thing.
So that gives us
some control there.
But there are other use cases
that maybe node affinity
doesn't help you with so well.
So say, you have a front-end
service and a back-end service
and you want them
to land together,
again to minimize latency.
They're talking to each
other all the time,
but they're not actually
in the same pod.
So these two processes ideally
are in the same availability
zone as well.
That's something that we call
north-south communication.
And you don't want
to have to say
they have to be in zone
B or zone C. You just
want them to be in the
same availability zone.
So that's something
that you can achieve
with inter-pod affinity.
Here it is again, require
during scheduling,
ignore during execution.
So again, we have
a topology key.
In this case, we just
say that's the zone.
And we have an
operator, which is in.
And we're saying
that our back end
should land in the same
zone as our front end.
We could say prefer
during scheduling,
ignore during execution.
And in this case,
we could also say
what happens at execution
is important as well.
So say something changes
in the cluster topology,
everything could move around.
So pods that were no
longer in the right place
because something changed
would move to another node.
Now one more quite
techie thing, and that's
taints and tolerations.
So imagine you
have one node which
has got some special hardware
on it, and two regular nodes.
So here we've got three nodes.
And one of them has a
couple of GPUs in it.
Say, for your use case,
Hygo, of video encoding.
And here we've
got a regular pod,
which is just going to do
some sort of regular job.
It doesn't particularly
need a GPU.
And it comes along and
the cluster is bare,
and it just gets scheduled
in the first node
that it comes to.
And that just happens to be
our GPU node, which is a shame.
Because next along
comes a GPU pod.
So by that I mean a pod
that's going to do some work
that would really benefit from
having access to that GPU.
But we could have this
scenario now where
we've already scheduled
something on our GPU node.
And it's basically full up.
There's no extra capacity there.
So either this GPU workload
won't get scheduled,
or it will have to
go somewhere else.
And effectively, our GPU,
our expensive GPU hardware
is wasted.
Well, we can solve
that with something
called taints and tolerations.
So this is quite simple really.
We can label our GPU node
with something called a taint.
So it's marked
that it has a GPU.
And we say, we use this
expression, prefer no schedule,
which just means it's
going to repel everything
that comes its way.
So it's saying, I
don't want any pods
unless when the GPU
pod comes along,
we've given it something
called a toleration.
So this pod can tolerate
running on a GPU node.
So we'll get the happy case
where the regular pod has not
been scheduled there because
it was repelled, because it
did not have that toleration.
But the pod with the
toleration for GPU,
the one the wants the
GPU, can take the slot.
And now we end up in
this happy scenario.
Now imagine, because we
say prefer no schedule,
imagine the case where our
regular pods have already
filled up all of the
available capacity,
and the only place left
to schedule something
is on the pod which has the GPU.
Well, that can happen
because of that preference.
So, it's a loose constraint.
So, how many people
in the audience,
hold up your hand
if you've heard
of this concept of an SRE,
a site reliability engineer.
So that's something we
believe in a lot at Google.
We literally wrote the book on
site reliability engineering.
It's a major contribution we
made to the dev-ops culture,
I would say.
Well, we want to
be your SRE too.
So Hygo talked about how
Google takes care of managing
your control plane for you.
This takes away a
lot of the pain.
So, routine ops-like
stuff you have to do,
like handling
backups, monitoring,
repairing the control plane
should something go wrong
in the availability zone
or wherever it is that
the physical hardware--
in this case it's
Container Engine--
so the availability zone.
We take care of
keeping it healthy.
And we can resize that control
plane for larger clusters.
And we aim to keep it running
for you all of the time.
And we also look after the
components on your node,
so the Kubernetes components.
So we give you things like
logging with stack driver,
integrated with stack
driver monitoring metrics.
We pre-install the
components needed
to act as a back end for
our global load balancer.
And now with 1.6, we can
manage your nodes too.
So we can handle
operating system updates,
security patches, Kubernetes
upgrades seamlessly.
And if there's a
problem, if there's
a problem with the kernel or
the VM, or it's out of memory,
or something else
is detected; we
can also drain the pods that
are running on there, if we can,
and restart that node and bring
up another one to replace it.
So you don't have to think
about that kind of thing.
And so that you can keep
track of all of that,
we have a full audit trail.
So you can tell whether
someone from your team
or the robot that took that
actions on your behalf.
So what's next?
Well, in 1.7 we've got
another release coming.
They come every three months.
And they're pretty much bang
on time all of the time.
We're going to have better
support for GPUs, which is now
a feature you can have on Google
Compute Engine and Container
Engine.
We're going to do more to
keep your secrets secret.
So you can integrate
with something
like Google Certificate
Manager or HashiCorp Vault
to store the secrets
that your services might
use to talk to each other or
things in the outside world.
We're going to have IP
virtual switch load balancing.
So that's a bit faster than
the existing built-in load
balancing using IP tables.
We're going to make it easier
for add-ons to integrate
with the core Kubernetes API.
And it's going to be
possible to upgrade
the components of Kubernetes on
a running cluster more easily.
And this is the thing--
Matt mentioned it
earlier-- the thing
that I'm most excited
about at the moment.
Because I'm really
interested in microservices.
And there are still
challenges with microservices.
Say, you hear the
story all the time
about how people are
breaking their monoliths down
into microservices.
But it does bring
some complexity.
Most successful microservices
stories started in that way,
breaking down some existing
thing into a monolith.
And everyone or every
developer at least,
is probably familiar with
dealing with concerns like, how
do I handle an HTTP failure.
How do I do HTTP
retries and exponential
back-off, and that
kind of thing,
perhaps in five languages?
How do I handle rate limiting
or internal load balancing in
between my services?
How do those services
really discover each other?
People are introducing all
sorts of additional frameworks
for service discovery.
Why should my
application have to think
about its own encryption,
when that could just
be handled by something at the
network level or service mesh?
And Istio brings you
all of those things.
So it's something that's
completely open source.
It's been designed to run on
any platform, any environment.
But first of all, it's
running on Kubernetes.
It's an effort
from the community.
So Google is obviously involved.
IBM and Lyft brought their Envoy
proxy, which is a super-fast--
it was already open source C++
Layer 7 proxy load balancer,
which automatically gets
injected next to your pods,
picks up the traffic, and
can handle all kinds of great
things like the things
I mentioned before,
or even canary releasing, or
directing traffic that comes
from a particular person to a
particular back end or version
of your service.
And you can try it out today.
So I think with just a couple
of commands you could install it
in a Kubernetes cluster running
locally or on Container Engine.
And there are some great
tutorials on the website.
If you go to the
tasks there, you
can get running with
canary releasing
and use a specific sort of A/B
testing and things like that,
more or less straight away.
So please have a
look at Istio.io.
And if you're not already
playing with a Kubernetes
cluster, you can do
that on your laptop.
So you could try
all of the features
I've talked about today by
installing MINICUBE, which is
represented by the first logo.
It's one command to
install it on a laptop.
And you have a running single
node, obviously a cluster.
Or you could take advantage
of Google Container Engine
and our free pricing tier.
So you get $300 a month, and you
could run a multi-node cluster
for quite a while on
Google Container Engine.
And try out all of these things
like multi-availability zones.
And have a look at
Istio, because I
think it's really cool.
I'll be down here at
the front immediately
afterwards, and then
out in the hall.
So if you have any questions,
please just come up to me
and ask.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]